the chair of the young lives commission
and former children's commissioner for
England and Longfield a very good
morning to you more than double the
number of children missing school
compared to pre-pandemic levels just how
concerned are you by that
well I along with many others are very
concerned about this I mean being out of
school on any long-term regular basis is
a disaster for all children for those
that are particularly vulnerable it can
be
catastrophic and we've heard from your
reports this morning these are often
children who are caring for relatives
often families who are struggling with
debts or homelessness it's much more
likely to be children on free School
meals much more likely to be children
with special educational needs and also
children with chronic mental health
conditions so for all of those children
they need the support and long-term
support to be able to get back into the
classroom
and why these numbers got so much worse
since the pandemic how much of a part
has that played
well it has certainly played a part I
mean these were problems that we knew
were developing before the pandemic we
knew that a lot of children were
um developing mental health conditions
or that we were much more aware of them
but of course the pandemic had a big
impact of that it just poured rocket
fuel on that and frankly since then
Services have been struggling to even
get to the point where they're catching
up mental health support is very
difficult for children to get hold of
thresholds have very high and of course
they're not attained in school but this
is also an indication of the lack of
support or the lack of levels and scales
of support needed for the children who
need it in school so yes there's
children who aren't attending
um severe absence as it's called but
there's also high levels of persistent
absence children who attend
um less than nine days
um uh missed one one day or more
um uh per fortnight and this kind of
long-term absence from school of course
it means that they're not getting the
education they need they're not being
with their friends they're also not
going to get those protective factors
that you know you get from school and
we're also very worried that some
children may just disengage and become
prey to those who want to exploit them
those are the more extreme cases but
certainly we're seeing an increase in
those incidents
the government has said that it's
expanding its attendance hubs and also
mental systems as well and they say they
support up to 600 schools how helpful
are they and is that enough
well of course they're helpful to bring
some benefits and some children will
um certainly be able to re-engage
um because of that but this is a much
bigger scale problem than this we're
talking about as you said
um thousands and thousands of children
and we know what works that's the
frustration the long-term support it
needs to enable those children Noble
those families to build the confidence
to build the capacity to be able to get
back into school my concern is that this
is becoming an entrenched problem
um and that if we don't fix it now it's
just storing up problems for the future
so what do you want to see happen now
well I would really like there to be
distinct money that is
um uh awarded for schools to be able to
build that support network around school
to be able to have an increase in mental
health support in schools to be able to
have many more youth workers working
with children to be able to build up
their resilience and get them into
school and also family workers too we
know that it takes time but we also know
that it's very possible and this is what
families and children tell us they need
okay well Anne Longfield chair of the
young lives Commission